de petits grains qui contiennent une
grande quantité d'informations ce pollen
vient tout juste d'être prélevés dans
cette ruche situé à plaisir
il prendra ensuite la direction de la
belgique pour être analysés les abeilles
allant à 3km allons donc possibilité
bureau de ramener énormément de
diversité florale de diversité de pollen
donc ce qui nous permet en mettant
devant chacune de nos ruches une trappe
à plein de savoir exactement quels sont
les fleurs qui sont mutinés c'est la
ferme de gally à saint cyr l'école qui
est à l'origine de cette étude
suite à des analyses du pollen de ses
ruches des carences concernant la
nourriture des abeilles ont été mises en
évidence
l'association de la plaine de versailles
qui regroupe 70 agriculteurs a décidé de
lancer une action à grande échelle
ça concerne tout le monde la
biodiversité c'est c'est notre
assurance-vie et les abeilles sont un
élément extrêmement important de la
biodiversité
on a souvent des projets qui sont à
l'échelle d'un apiculteur mais de
vouloir impliquer tout un territoire
avec les agriculteurs les habitants et
les communes ça je pense pas que ça se
fasse ailleurs 30% des abeilles meurent
chaque année en france
les causes de cette mortalité sont
multiples même si à plaisir elles sont
plutôt épargné cet apiculteur a choisi
de prendre part à ce projet afin de
pouvoir mettre en place un plan d'action
et lutter pour leur sauvegarde
c'est vraiment le premier prélèvement
que je réalise et je souhaite bien sûr
continuer à faire ce genre de choses
le plus longtemps possible puisque ça
permettra aussi don de définir et de
caractériser notre biodiversité sur sur
la plaine de versailles
pour l'instant quatre ruches installées
sur ce territoire sont concernés par
cette étude qui s'étale sur trois amis